- Yeah lets Facetime him right now.
What up my guy?
What are you doing?
This guy can dance his fucking ass off,
I'll tell you all about it when I see you.
You've got your perspective.
(hip hop music)
(backwards music)
What's up blog?
...flight from New York, to L.A.
here for digital up fronts,
for PureWow One37 pm, we're
going to some events now.
Promoting all our things for
2019, so that advertisers
and brands can get
excited and spend with us.
And then we'll take some
potential and current clients
out to dinner, big summit, keynote, so
should be a good day.
One37pm, I'm Gary Vaynerchuk, I've been
an entrepreneur my whole life.
Over the last three to five years,
what has probably become
apparent to a lot of people
in this room is that
entrepreneurship has been put
on a cultural pedestal and
navigating through the media
and advertising landscape
as I have, it became very
obvious to me that the way
I live my life and many
others which is entrepreneurship
being the thing that
I most identify with being
the filter that I take
sports or fashion or any
parts of culture through,
became a white space that
a lot of people weren't
really addressing.
One37pm's mission in 2019
is to continue establishing
what it's been able to do.
We're looking to build
massive pillars that we think
are ownable for the brands
associated with those executions,
whether it's the 30 most
entrepreneurial athletes,
whether it is Superbowl,
whether it is a series
we're calling Face to Face time.
Thanks for your attention,
I hope the day's going
well, I'm sure it's long,
I hope to see some of you soon, thank you.
(applause)
Oh wait, Ryan you're
taking pictures of talent?
Talent, and one weird executive.
Yeah let's Facetime him right now.
See if we can get him.
(laughing)
You love him?
He's amazing.
- He's pretty dope.
My dude! What up my guy?
What are you doing?
Where are you?
- I'm in Atlanta.
- That's what's up, you in the studio?
Say what's up to my guy.
- [Gunna] What's up bro?
- I'm a big fan.
- This guy can dance his fuckin' ass off,
I'll tell you all about it when I see you.
You been good?
- [Gunna] Where you at?
- I'm in L.A., I just did
an upfront with my guy here
and he opened for our media
company, that One37pm,
that new site where I'm just gonna write a
ton of shit about you.
I'll tell you all about it
when I see you next, man.
I've been watching man,
I'm real happy for you man,
I'm so fuckin' proud for you.
I'm gonna be in Atlanta a
bunch, I'm gonna be in Atlanta
for Superbowl and I'm gonna
be in New York and L.A.
a whole bunch the next couple months.
- [Gunna] I'll be in New
York like next week, so.
- Hit me, hit me, hit me.
Sending you love, good to see you. (kiss)
- [Gunna] Love.
(hip hop music)
- Fuckin' mugs, coffee
mugs, Hammonds, coffee mugs.
They're at every fucking garage sale for
20 fucking five cents, and
they're all worth four to $30,
it's fucking ridiculous.
Stuffed animals and coffee
mugs are more likely to
get to 99% to the place
they want to get to then
their bullshit brand, street
wear brand and fuckin'
startup pack, that's the fuckin' truth.
For 99% of you watching
now, the 2500 of you that
are live right now, for 99%
of you that are trying to
get to 100,000 a year,
it's a quicker path,
an easier path, the more
likely path that you go to
garage sales, yard sales,
flea markets, and Goodwills
and buy fuckin' ceramic
coffee mugs and fuckin'
stuffed animals and flip
your way to 100,000,
than building the next
Supreme or Instagram.
That's fuckin' facts.
(hip hop music)
Make it much louder.
(rap music)
(hip hop music)
How ya doing? Good?
How's it going so far?
How you doing?
- This conference is poppin'.
- Yeah?
- Like 10x last year, I'm so happy dude.
- This is the greatest era
of fake entrepreneurship.
- Absolutely.
(laughs)
- Well, look you've built
such a great brand around
helping people build that up too, so.
- Well it's funny, even if
you look at where I'm getting
excited about content, I'm
like pushing more to go
like garage sale-ing and make $1000.
- The Garbage Talk, that's a cool idea.
- Trash Talk.
- Yeah Trash Talk.
- Yeah I'm like literally,
there's so many reasons
why it's happening.
First of all, I just seriously
thing that going garage
sale-ing might be my
favorite thing on earth.
- You remember you and AJ
telling me about doing it?
- Yeah, by the way, this
is crazy I just remembered.
We almost did it on revision three.
- Yeah that's right.
- I think me and AJ
almost did, this is real,
we almost did Trash Talk,
literally what I did
like two weeks ago, on
revision three, nine years ago.
I wish you knew how
fuckin' young you were,
you haven't even fuckin' started.
How old are you?
I would rip my arm off and give up
everything I have to be 19.
That's how much advantage time is.
It's the asset.
And so to be this far along
and think this entrepreneurial,
and have this internet, and this maturity.
- The right mindset.
- If I was a 15 year
old right now, I'd be,
first of all I would have
never graduated high school,
second of all I would be a
fuckin' quadrillionaire and
be the happiest fucker of all time.
I would garage sale all day long.
(laughs)
I'd be making like 97
million a year buying stuff
at flea markets and flipping it.
(hip hop music)
Cause I want everyone in
this room to get value out
of this talk and I'm not
sure if there's anything
else I can say better than
what I'm about to say,
and I really need you to understand it.
The bigger the image that
everybody here like myself
that's over 40 has, is we've lived through
an economic meltdown.
We lived through it, thus,
we anticipate it in a
different way that if
you're under 32 you can't.
Because if you've only
lived life professionally in
an environment where the
economy's been flourishing,
you don't realize what
happened, which is literally
tomorrow morning you can
wake up and we can have
some sort of event that
completely starts the collapse
of the economy and all of
a sudden the DMs from a
detox tea or from Pepsi or Coach stop.
Let me tell you what stops
when the economy collapses.
People don't wanna just
buy a $22 t-shirt that
has a funny saying on it.
Big brands don't want to pour
money, because they don't
have it, into the market.
Context in understanding
what's happening right now
in the global economy,
this is all growing,
but it's growing during a time of frothy,
massive economic growth.
So if you're sitting here
and you strategy is I'm
gonna get off of my job and
I'm gonna get into this,
or I'm now making 80k a
year doing this, but I'm
about to go to a half
a million, you have to
contextualize the moment we're in.
I tell entrepreneurs all
the time and I don't want to
razz, but I want everybody
to wrap their head around it.
If you're not crushing it
right now as an entrepreneur,
you suck.
(rock music)
Everybody here, if you're
lucky enough to have a very
elderly family member and/or
if you just want to give
back and go to a retirement
home, go spend time,
I think the reason I have
wisdom, is from a very young
age but who knows why, as a
kid I'd go to the playground,
and my friends would have
their grandparents visit,
and this is just down to like
DNA, like unexplainable shit,
I would like run off and like
sit with 80 year olds and
ask random ass shit.
I've always been so
gravitating towards that.
What it taught me is the
only thing I don't want
to have is regret.
Regret is poison, it's poison.
So like I'd rather lose
and have all of you laugh
at me, then sit at 91
on a bench and be like,
Fuck, I really wish I had
that person follow me around
with a camera or whatever it may be.
So like just don't have regret.
Cool, awesome, take care everyone.
Thanks everyone.
(hip hop music)
My dude.
- Awww fella!
- I think where you are
in your career right now,
you do a song with a cross-over
Main Street, Wal-mart
big brand person, when
I say brand a human?
I think it would change
the course of your career.
What Kendrick did, and he
was further along at that
point when he did it, but
when I saw Kendrick put out
a song with Taylor Swift
like four years ago,
I was like game over.
- Game over.
It's smart.
Now to me the question
becomes you know, is there
something actually authentic.
You know what I would do if I were you?
Straight up, I would start
listening to the radio,
while you're driving around,
just if you hear something,
you be like Yo who's that?
And be like who the fuck is- whatever.
You see where I'm going?
Then that way it's
authentic, then you're like
yo I fucked with this song.
- Yeah.
- You know what I mean?
- Like just picking
somebody out of thin air.
- Exactly or just take
the top 100 on Spotify and
just fuckin' listen to it when
you're livin', and be like
oh that sounds- and it's
like some rock band,
or some pop girl, and then
it can be authentic to you.
Because they need you too.
(hip hop)